all right Ilana mm-hmm a lot of where'd
you grow up where you from originally
Camarillo see you're an LA girl yeah and
tell me where your shop it did you have
both parents growing up well I was
adopted
oh really yeah but I came here when I
was an infant so you know it's all the
same but my parents are Caucasian you
know upper class teachers good childhood
yeah you know I sheltered real sheltered
early yeah
beyond sheltered but uh yeah okay kid
were you in high school you know what I
really I could actually you know what my
parents didn't really let me do too much
so I I was kind of a rebellious you know
where I uh would try to have fun but not
you know but on the down down low but
then my dad he passed away when I was in
high school so it was just my mom and my
brother and I so I kind of you know
decided to I actually was pretty smart
in high school so I ended up going to
junior college while I was in high
school so I could slip away a break away
from the house since I was never able to
go anywhere usually but but it was
that's okay you know
did you go to college yeah I did I did
go to college but I was graduated before
I was 20
oh really yeah so
yeah but then I got caught up with the
wrong people
so is it we got you into this career
yeah pretty much start dating a guide
that my mom thought was in his 20s when
he was in his 40s yeah
and that's where it all began were there
like things like drugs and drugs sex
parties you name it
oh yeah he was a freak that's about
where everything turned for me I guess
and when at what point did you start
working as a exactly dancer stripper um
how about when I was 23 Katie - 23
so rather than pursuing a career that
was yeah some of you studied in school
you yeah yeah yeah I'll never forget I
was at a friend's house and I didn't I
have no idea I had not never even
smelled what marijuana was I did not
even know what we'd smelled like and
then like we had found some a baggie I
could talk about this very first a
baggie of white stuff when I was like
what is this and then my boyfriend the
time he came over and he was like oh let
me tell you what those that is cocaine
and it was all my life changed at that
point yeah but we would go to these
parties and yeah he was a freak freak
and then I just figured out that was
kind of fun for me you know so well like
I've been missing it all my whole life
so I'm like okay so your childhood was
kind of sheltered you know so sheltered
it was like he became a wild kid we were
oh that was a freak yeah yeah did you
have kids of your own
mm-hmm they were married mm-hmm nope so
you work at some of the strip clubs in
the valley or in LA I used to like a
couple of them but now it's just private
parties because I'm older now you know
yeah I need to make more money and you
make more money being a private oh yeah
totally totally because there's you know
I mean and things go beyond just
the dance you know what I mean so what
whatever that's fine I understood you
know I'm gonna unattach so I can do
whatever I want to do yeah but you like
bachelor parties and yeah oh yeah the
guys are having a good time and uh huh
yeah you get to make some extra money
yeah a lot of extra money so that's cool
yeah I've met a lot of people that you
know the networking thing is really good
it's probably better lifestyle than
working till all hours of the strip
program yeah totally yeah and even and
people in the strip clubs they don't
really pay you that much you know I mean
so yeah it's a lot better you just get
your you you make your deal before hands
more business in that sense if that
makes sense yeah do you still use any
drugs I do what's your drug today gee
Bruce G GHB it's the date rape drug oh
is that right yeah so you take it what
does it do for you make you just not
care about anything and do it it makes
you like any inhibitions you have gone
oh really
yeah so you'll take it and you'll stay
at home when you do this so you'll go
out I'll go out yeah you're not supposed
to like be driving on something that bad
I just got into trouble this is not any
trouble
no I totally like know my limits okay so
that's good but some people when they
take it it's all bad but thank God it
doesn't it's not bad for me but so it's
kind of like drinking alcohol weird
yeah without a hangover you're in a
short-term it's like 3-4 hours really
good yes you take it as a pill it's a
liquid it looks like water mmm just like
a little bottle cap full it's not much
interesting yeah tastes like salty balls
but um yeah it's good
and so ever do you looking back at your
life do you ever wish you did maybe
would you what regrets might you have
you know what I I hate to say it but
like I really I mean I don't really I I
don't know I I don't really like to look
at my life and look forward any regrets
you know I mean like that's like my
biggest fear to like be on my deathbed
and go oh my god I regret this I feel
bad about this
you know what I mean I really I don't
feel bad about it at all I used to go up
to myself I mean I used to I worked at
the mall at one point okay before I got
you know really freaky and I remember
making friends there and since I wasn't
like one to like have slumber parties
and all that stuff you know when I was
growing up so I you know made new
friends at the mall and I remember I
used to I just threw all their
boyfriends so maybe that's what I regret
because you know they don't really look
good on that then you kind of lose your
friends you know that's kind of lame but
other than that at the time I didn't
care yeah so if your parents know that
you're doing this no they still don't
know yeah you've been doing all these
years what are you tell them you're
doing uh food delivery really
they may no no no no there's a lot of a
lot of videos I need to define I mean
honestly as long as I don't ask them for
help then they think everything's fine
I kind of like that right you know I
mean so it kind of works out of my favor
but if I ask them for help and they'll
ask me
they'll look more into my life do you
know what I mean so I'm sure you I'm
sure you got some crazy stories of
working as a stripper all these years oh
yeah Lots
there has been some freaks and you know
I used to I started dating this one guy
who was a girl trapped in a man's body
so that was kind of interesting
okay but he was a lesbian trapped in a
minute I know it sounds weird but you
know and then uh he had nice likes of me
he had long black hair but um but he
introduced me to a lot of like people
and by for people he was under my
current but which was interesting yeah
he was a guy in front of them but then
when we go to these other parties it was
interesting but but we used to like go
you know he would like you know me and a
couple girls would go like you know they
would have their parties and stuff and
it was it was good it was fun it would
be like you know it just turned out to
be more you know sexual do you know what
I mean mmm so yeah yeah but what advice
would you give a young girl it's
considering this as a career
you know just you know I don't know I
just feel like I can be easily persuaded
you know I mean like and it's kind of
weird because like you're out there
everything's out in the open it's like
you should have a fear of rejection do
you know I mean so you kind of go along
with the program
I don't know I just feel like just keep
your stand up for yourself when you need
to you you know and but do what you want
to do you know it's your only life you
have so do you feel like this who you
are today is more who Alana is then
maybe who you you were as is it oh yeah
when you pit with your parents oh yeah
this is where they are yeah in your
Asian right you're trying in Korean
mm-hmm do you think are there more
Koreans Asians that might be the wilder
and freer as you are oh yeah totally and
they're very repressed oh yeah because
of the culture big time can be parents
yeah cuz I had some friends that were
like Korean and even high school you
know cuz I would like you know sneak out
of my house like I literally got to
learn how to put my car in neutral we
had a driveway that went down put my car
in neutral in the middle of the night
coast down the parents never knew when I
came home you know but and they would be
like oh would you do last night you know
I'm like oh I went out with that you
know
but they they would be like it would be
all bad if they had wanted to do that
yeah I know they were totally like
repressed and like you know Mary I mean
but I know the wild was in them but yeah
I don't know I just think in the end you
it makes you unhappy if you can't do
what you want to do and be who you want
to be absolutely you know I mean I can't
say I'm unhappy with myself or anybody
else like like things are good so I
can't blame it's great mm-hmm
all right well thank you so much for
talking with me and good luck with
whatever you end up doing here okay
thank you
you